how would you like to start the new year
off with a lump of cash
the jackpots for both mega millions and
powerball are well over 400 million
dollars yeah the drawing for mega
millions top prize is on tuesday evening
the powerball drawing
is on wednesday okay here's where we
bring the reality and the odds of a
single lotto ticket
getting it is about one in 290 million
ted should we send a new guy over to
state line to get us some tickets what
do you think
you you ready my mind because they used
to do that to me they would have
everybody in the newsroom would give me
a lump of cash
and have me go down to california on the
border there
and get this lot of tickets i should
have just ran away with the cash
i will stand in line for you guys
christian we'll send you
the 45-minute drive and then you'll wait
in line we greatly appreciate that
that's christian's assignment tomorrow
yes christian and we will have food here
for you when you return i
promise you right
all right well we're gonna find out more
about christian coming up in just a
little bit